Mark: Alright Wade
Jack: There's just a lone watermelon in the way/room
M: Wa- Wade, I'm not going to make fun of you
like everyone else did.
because you i-id you are arguably just as bad as I am at this...
Wade: YEAH
Mark: YEAH
M: So TOGETHER...
J: Oh god there's two of them
Bob: OH! Fuck me!
Jack: There's two of them
M: We can do this
B: Why is this like this?
B: AGH!
M: Okay, you lead the way.
Taunt: YEAHEHEAH
W: I think they're this way.
Mark & Wade: *giggles*
M: That sounded like you Bob
Jack: NO...
B: It kinda did
Taunt: COME TO PAPA
M: Come to Papa. Come to BIG. PAPA. PUMP
Mark: Come on
Come over here
Wade: OH IT'S THE G-MAN
Mark: Oh...I don't think that's them...
Mark: Where you guys at?
Bob: Nowhere?
J: Uhhhh... Nowhere
B: Everywhere
Mark: Uh huh
M: Big Papa Pump doesn't like being LIED to!
J: But I wanna be a horse dick
we-we-we've been here before, we can't be the horse di-
*MARKIPLIER BURPS LOUDLY* "-ick"
J: I know. Why do we return to this misery?
M: *wesouoich
M: It's not that bad
J: Well see you later
*Bob sucks in air*  M: Wait What
bob: *laughing THEN COUGHS*
Mark: Wade, I feel like I'm being made a fool of!
*BOB LAUGHING*
Jack: WE BOTH WERE!
Mark: Neither I or you.
Wade: Wait a minute.
Jack: Ooohhhhhhh fuck.
Wade: *muffled hmmmm* *Taunt in the background*
Wade: Wait Mark, are you the one taunting?!
Mark: Yeah of course I am!
*Bob and Jack then others start to laugh*
Mark: Wait were you looking for my taunts? *others still laughing*
Mark : You idiot!
Wade: What do you mean me- you- me
*mark laughs* Wade: You're right.
*Wade laughs*
Wade: When you're right, you're right boss.
*Mark laughing* Jack: What do you mean- *??*
Mark: Uhh boy we are not looking good today Wade.
Mark: We are not looking good.
W: Well no considering I've been trying to track you this whole time.
*Mark and Bob laughing*
*Taunt*
Wade: Oh come on! Stop it Mark!
*Bob and Mark laughing*
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Alright, I'll stop it man.
Mark: Are they taunting? Are you guys taunting? *Bob in background ooooh*
Bob: I'm not taunting.
Wade: One of them is taunting, one of them is outside.
Bob: You guys have been all over my steez this whole time.
Mark: *confused* What?
Mark: Okay Wade, are they out here?
Wade: I think one is on the other side of this wall,
Wade : Or right around here.
Mark: Okay
Wade: Probably the other side of the wall.
Mark: Alright.
Mark : Other side of the wall, like the fence?
*Jack makes a soft weee sound*
Bob: *starts laughing*
*Bob makes a teehee noise* *Mark starts laughing*
Mark: I don't like being made fun of.
Mark: *growls* Come on guys–Woah.
Geezus, I can get up there...
Mark: Oh!
Wade: Oh no, I'm stuck, oh god
Mark: Hey Wade, look at me!
Wade look at ME!
Wade: uh, UH
Wade: I can't get outta this box!
Mark: WADE
Bob: I see you riding that horse, Mark.
Mark: Waaaade
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Look at meeee!
Wade: Mark, I'm comin'!
Mark: Hi-ho, silver! Yahooooo!
Wade: Oh hang on, lemme get a thumbnail,
Mark: Thanks. WEEEEE!
Bob: Whip it real good, Mark.
Mark: Put my face on it! Put my face all big.
Put my face all big on this.
Wade: Yeah. Jack: *fuck...* Mark: Yeah, OK?
Wade: Ah, your face is gonna go right HERE!
Mark: YAH!
*Bob laughing, inaudible chatter*
Mark: Thanks man.
Bob: Wait, can I get a thumbnail too?
Mark: Aww, I just got off
Bob: Go back up there! Go back up there!
Mark: Alright. Wade: Oh I thought I- I saw you-
Mark: Yee-haw! *falls off*
Wade: You can do it Mark. Mark: Yee- yee-  Yee-haw!
Bob: Yee- yaw hooooooo.
Mark: Yippie-ky-yay-yo.
Bob: I mean I guess I'm sorta on your team now cause I'm- *pause* Pretty sure that if I run you're just gonna shoot me, so-
Mark: Uh, no-no, we won't shoot you.
We won't shoot you.
Bob: Yeah, you say that, but Wade does not agree to that. I'm like, 98% sure. *Mark laughs*
Mark: Wait, help us find Jack.
Bob: *laughs continuously*
Mark: We know he's the smarter of the two of you so we gotta get...
Mark: We gotta combine our heads. Bob: Alright
Bob:  I'll be the saw blade of destiny,  come with me to find jack.
Jack: Fucken *??* Mark: Alright
(Bob makes toy car sounds)
Mark: *laughs* It's a Roomba!
Mark: You're a fuckin' Roomba
*Bob starts laughing*
*Bob makes rrrr noises*
Bob: I'm a Roomba rrrrr
*Mark and Wade start laughing*
W: but where does the dirt go?
B: rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr M: *laughing*
M: It's-it's-it's hilarious
B: ertss errts errrrrrts
M: *laughing*
J: Where the fuck are you guys? M: Wade I can't believe you don't find this halarious
like i do. W: I'm enjoying it, don't get me wrong
M: I'm just so easily amused!
J: (inaudiable) W: The rotation is what really sells it
M: *laughs*
J: *laughs*
M: It's really convincing! B: You still with me?
B: I don't know what sounds I-Oh my God M:OOOOHHHH
MY ROOMBA!
B: Fucking cleaning the floors! M: Goddammit Wade!
B: You're welcome!
W: He broke. It was time
J: Well, well, well
J: Welp
B: Were you in the same spot the whole time Jack?
J: No no I was following you guys around. B: Oh okay
W: Oh.. *Bob laughs*
J: I was for awhile I was a big giant box that was-
M: Hey W-Wade do you think we can be this thing? *laughs*
*Bob laughs*  *Wade grunts*
J: *inaudible, somthing about watermelons* M: Wait hang on... Let me get... Let me hop in. Oh shIT-
*Mark and Wade laugh*
J: What are you guys doin'? *Mark and Wade continue to laugh*
M: Wait turn on rotation lock! They'll never know! *Wade coughs*
W: They'll neeeever see, oh this one's coming to join me! *Mark laughs*
J: tHIS one?
*Mark laughs* B: Oh my god. *Bob, Wade, and Mark laugh*
M: Oh no! I think they spotted us!
W: That's cause you didn't have rotation lock on! M: Oh sorry.
B: Yeah no dude if you had rotation lock on, come on man!
M: I just turned it on B: WoAH. Wade I think you and that other car are becoming one right now.
*Mark laughs* W: Yeah we are TOTALLY *inaudible as Bob, Mark, and Jack laugh*
M: Jack! Jack help! J: Does this help?
M: Help! *Bob continues to laugh* Help please!
M: Oh god
B: Here
*mixture of whimpers and car noises*
B: We'll just give you guys cones
J: Yeah, I'm tryin– I'll try and push you guys out
J: Wait, which one is the real car?
*Mark laughs*
W: I don't know
B: The one– the one that's in the– the one that's in like a reasonable position is the real car I think
M: Wait, Wade,  you're a tank, I'm your turret *noise*
B: oOH shit *Mark noise*
J: Oh no I'm stuck *another Mark noise*
W: I'm falling through the earth!
J: *quiet 'Goddammit'* *and Mark noise again*
J: I'm stuck
*still noisy Mark?*
B: I got– oh no I'm stuck!
*Mark plz stahp*
M: Now we're all stuck guys
(B: now I'm unstuck, okay)
B: Mark, I'm gonna try–Mark Mark, aim your hood at me, I'm gonna try and land a cone on you
M: Okay
W: Hey
J: I'm tryin' to push you
B: *tries* *fails* Alright it doesn't go that far
M: Alright yeah, that sucked
B: Hyuh! Yeeeeaaaah
M: OW it's inside me
W: I can't see any of– J: Keep clicking– keep turning–
B: Yeeeaaaah
M: Bob, stop stuffing me with your cones
B: Hyuuh! *throws*
M: Geezus!
B: WOAH! Geezus christ
J: *inaudible but still stuck*
M: Wait, yeah. Wait, hey!
J: OH OH OH!
M: Wait, hold–aww I thought I made it
*Jack inaudible*
M: Woah, I'm free look!
B: Oh hey but–wait, no, Mark
B: You need to have my cones inside you or you're not complete
M: Wait, wait
W: OHHH, Mark
J: Wade, you're just getting pounded into the ground
M: (overlaps) I'm off to work guys! *car noise*
W: Make us proud, Mark!
*car noise continues*
W: Make us prooouuuuud
J: That's just sad
B: C-can I get a lift buddy
M: Yeah, sure. I'm your Uber driver J: Oh me too
M: Hop on guys B: lets do this guys
B: Mark the Uber driver, take us- M: *Car noise* B: Take us downtown to-
B&W: Aw M: *laughs* uh
J: Fuckin no stars for you B: hang on, hang on, hang on
M: Rate me five stars! Rate me five stars!  B: Hang on, no, hang on
B: Hang on M: Please! B: Hang on, hang on. Let me-
B: Let me- we can do this, we can work this out, let me get on the- aww I'm stuck
B: Alright, there we go. Let me get on the hood W: *throws cone at Bob* huh! M: Okay
B: and then let me, let me know when you're gonna- Would you stop that?! M: Woah
J: I'm blocking off traffic B: let me, let me know when you're going to go, Ok?
M: Okay I'm gonna go
B: Okay go. M: do you want me to crawl go? Alright *Car noises*
*Wade laughs* W: that cone is blocking-
M: I seem to have hit an obstacle *continued car noises*  W: man the traffic cone
B: th-these fucking cones! *Mark laughs* B: OhMyGod I'm stuck, I'm so stuck
B: Woah hey *More Car noises* * weird noise that sort of resembles a car stopping*
M: Alright *Everyone laughs* J: Fuckin B: Ohh jeez
M:Alright, Wade. We kinda dissapointed- wha- Wade
M: Why did you look at the Car first?
M:What are the odds? W: Actually that would be the worst place for us to look.
M: *still laughing* Oh, Ok. Alright then
M: they're concentrating W: There's a melon down here (inaudible) There's a rolling mellon!
J: *breathes* M: Huh? J: That's always there B: *laughing*
M&B: *laughing*
M: Ohh. B: *laughing* Did I really just get away with that?
M: I dunno W: All I saw was a melon B I was a dresser. I went right between you guys.
W: I knew I saw a dresser down here! B:A fucking dresser and then I tried to become
one and I like flew into the air and then you guys were in the wrong room
and I was like M: *laughing* B: *making weird noises*
M: I want an instant slow-mo replay if you actually showed up in my screen *giggling*
W: I saw (inaudible) M: Oh, hi. Hello. Who's that? J:Nooo M: Who's that? Huh? Where yah going? Where the fuck did you go?
J: Fawk M: Where did you go?... What? B: OH no. NOO. Anything but this
M: Wait.. Oh, I see what happened *laughing*  J: Are you SERIOUS? *giggling* hoh my god
J:I feel BAD for you. Don't have kids, please M: Here (x3) B:  *laughing*
M:Wait, I'll give you a peace offering.
M: I don't know how I missed that, but..
J: I can B: Um M: Yeah
J: WHOAH M: There yah go B: Uuummm
M: FRIDGE ON THE RUN B: Ummmmm
J:You're holding a giant error! B: Ummmmm
M: Oh wow Wade where did you get that gun?
W: It was in one of the balls
M: OH. J&B: Oh Wade you're holding a giant error to me
*Bob laughs*
M: I see a really impressive gun Wade
M: It's really big!
M: I bet it hurts when you shoot him >:D
B: Why-...
W: Let's find out >:D
M: woAH
J: You kill me- B: -Why an error
B: Why is this working?!
B: Jack, what do I look like right now?
J: *impressed* Oh my GODD
*Jack and Bob laugh, a LOT*
*Both still laughing* J: WHY?!xD B:Why is this working!?
J: I don't know! M: What the fuck?! *Bob laughs very loudly*
*Bob screeches in laughter*
W: oh
M: I did not notice that!! *Bob still can't stop laughing xD*
W: I didn't either!!
M: How did....?!?!
B: I was watching you fucking chase jack around
M:It's so weird because when you walk in-
-from this angle it almost looked normal
for a-*laughs*
B: Hey guys how's it going. W: Ya! Ya it did
M: Yeah it was super weird J: I put the *something* inside you Bob.
B: I couldn't even see outside of my own... *dies* oh there we go
W: *angry shooting yelling* M: Oh jeez
M: No don't error me bro!
M: *quietly* don't error me. J: *laughs*
M: Alright. J: That was an embarrassing round, not getting better for you guys.
*laughter* M: Hey... it's ok
M: oh, im out of, oh
M: Alright it's fine. B: Oh hey buddy
W: hey..... are you..?
B: Whats up tire friend?
M: Wait, Wade. B: oh no no no no no
J: Oh my. *Laughter*
M: NOOOO!!!!! *Bob laughs loudly*
M: NOO!!!!! J: You're fuckin' flawless dude
M: Nooo! J: C'mon here
J: Check the horses donut hole
M: *laughs* B: Alright Wade I'll give you - give you- you go first, okay buddy?
M: Wait Wade, come to the horse W: Alright, oh
*Bob laughing
M: We're gonna give this bad boy wheels W: (inaudible)
B: Wade doesn't fit through doors right now J: *laughs*
W: I can fit through doors now
*all laugh*
M: Aw, that's not a wheel *laughs*
B: Aw, hey
M: We'll make do. We'll make do B: You guys were going for the same prop
M: Wade get on the right leg, ill get on the left leg
M: This bad boy is gonna go places * everyone starts to laugh